this video was made possible by class
central which lets you watch tens of
thousands of lectures from top
universities from the comfort of your
home click the link in the description
to check it out let's discuss the
pseudoscience of detoxes and cleanses
including diets pills supplements herbs
drinks face masks skin patches or
anything that claims to purge your body
of impurities with no foundation in
medical science let's be clear the word
detox can also mean drug and alcohol
dependency treatments and programs that
could be scientifically sound or even
the actual act itself of withdrawing
from drugs or alcohol you might say
someone has alcohol dependency
they've stopped drinking they're in the
hospital being treated so they're in a
detox program the concept of detoxing in
that sense is not what we're talking
about here the word detox isn't always a
scam sometimes it's medically legitimate
such as dialysis which cleanses the
blood of people who have impaired
kidneys in this video when I say cleanse
or detox I'm not talking about those I'm
talking about
alternative medicine treatments that
claim to rid the body of poorly defined
toxins and are medically discredited
detox defenders say that harmful toxins
and chemicals accumulate in our bodies
but our vague or inaccurate in
identifying the toxins if actual toxins
are building up in your body and your
body can't release them that is a
diagnosable disorder toxins don't build
up in healthy people the way that the
detox peddlers claim toxin has become as
pseudoscience buzzword toxins of course
exist but if cleanses named these toxins
they could be measured before and after
a detox treatment but it's often the
case conveniently that people selling
detoxes don't identify the toxins the
toxins supposedly come from the air we
breathe the food we eat and we need to
undergo a cleanse to sort of hit the
reset button on our bodies to revive the
body or a certain part of the body
all amount of toxins do exist in our
food and are even produced by our bodies
but our bodies have mechanisms to remove
them like the liver and the kidneys the
proponents of detoxes will incorrectly
tell you that under normal circumstances
there's tons of extra harmful muck
building up getting stuck to the walls
of your digestive tract for example and
that you need to flush it all out every
so often this gunk can make you feel
tired anxious depressed bloated whatever
else the debunked detox has come in many
forms you can buy adhesive patches as
cleansing detox footpads which you wear
while you sleep and when you take them
off in the morning you can just see all
the toxins that came out they're
actually just designed to change color
when they contact your natural foot
moisture another popular one is to
eliminate toxins through sweating
profusely the idea being that you can
pump impurities out of your body by
causing perspiration in high-temperature
environments people will do it by going
to the sauna or hot yoga sweating out
toxins is a myth human sweat to lower
their body temperature not to evacuate
harmful substances that's what our
kidneys and liver do sweat is mostly
water salt and potassium
another common cleanse is the juice diet
when you're either buying or making
juices from raw fruits or vegetables
sometimes these juices are all you eat
for the duration of the cleanse if
you're eating or drinking mostly fruit
you miss iron zinc vitamin D calcium
omega-3 fatty acids this can lead to
anemia tiredness and a depleted immune
system too much fruit can cause high
blood sugar it can cause heartburn it
can cause acid reflux and other
conditions many cleanses also involve
eating just excessive amounts of
cruciferous vegetables like broccoli
Brussels sprouts kale or cabbage these
foods are really great for your health
in reasonable quantities not if it's all
you eat vegetables like these contain
thiocyanate switch can affect your
body's ability to absorb iodine which
can lead to hypothyroidism Const
patient dry skin and other issues eating
only fruits and vegetables can also mean
you're missing protein which your immune
system needs to regenerate muscle to
have healthy hair and healthy
fingernails protein is an essential
building block of all kinds of tissue in
your body many diets that consist
exclusively of fruits and sometimes
vegetables are low in calories so people
can use them to lose weight which works
your body responds to the lack of
calories you'll lose a lot of glycogen
you'll lose a lot of water weight but
ultra low calorie crash diets yield what
are often superficial results and
they're not sustainable and as soon as
you start eating normally again the body
will return to its previous state often
you're not getting the nutrients you
need especially if you're eating or
drinking one type of food which is
common in these cleanses it might not
hurt you because you just don't keep it
up for too long although it actually can
harm your body it definitely doesn't
give you any long-term tools for what
you're trying to accomplish whether it's
weight loss or overall health and it
definitely doesn't remove the so-called
toxins from your system another popular
way to remove toxins from your body is
by flushing your bowels either by
ingesting laxatives or through colonics
many people falsely believe that toxins
are left behind and your intestines or
colon when you digest food and that it
needs to be cleared but your bowels
don't work the way that someone pushing
detox makes you think healthy bodies
absorb what they should from food and
the rest comes out it doesn't get stuck
during the process barring an acute
medical issue if you're healthy your
bowels are clear enough from your body's
normal functions and there's no
scientific evidence that colonics are
good for your health or actually flush
anything harmful out and colonics can
also be dangerous the
Gastroenterological community says it's
generally a bad idea
to force flush a healthy person's colon
no matter how you do it and it can cause
unpleasant side effects the hydration
nausea vomiting cramping bloating and
these are only some of
things that : cleansing has been proven
to cause in the US the FDA regulates the
production of the equipment that's used
for this kind of thing but not the use
and that's sort of the issue with a lot
of this stuff drinks and supplements
that brand themselves as detox products
usually have to abide by safety
standards during the manufacturing
process but the FDA doesn't require
these companies to scientifically
substantiate their claims about the
effects of their products because they
aren't actually classified as
medications in 2009 the nonprofit cents
for science contacted 15 companies which
manufacture detox products and they
asked for evidence of their claims the
products included pills smoothies
shampoos none of the 15 companies came
up with evidence and they couldn't even
specify which toxins their product
actually removes from people's bodies
yet this is a massive industry and it's
going to remain massive as long as
people willingly waste their money on
this stuff but why do people do it we
also sometimes hear about air and water
pollution
those are real and we feel like our
bodies are under assault from these
things and in some situations we might
be like for example the scientifically
proven connections between air pollution
and asthma that's real but those
problems aren't going to be solved by
pseudoscience detoxes we know a big part
of this is the placebo effect you just
paid money for something you were told
it was going to work you're expecting
that it will work and the extreme nature
itself with many so-called treatments is
part of the appeal it really feels like
you're doing something major it feels
sort of like okay I'm consuming nothing
but liquid kale or I'm shooting gallons
of water into my colon it's unpleasant
it must be doing something and people do
want to have more control over their
bodies
then we often actually do for example
even if the symptoms someone is trying
to treat with the detox is real someone
might turn to detoxes because there
might not be a sufficient solution to
the problem or using a detox might seem
like a faster or easier solution
to the problem then what doctors might
recommend like improving your diet over
the long term or developing an exercise
program getting better sleep on a
consistent basis the fear of taking
pharmaceutical drugs can also be a
factor many people irrationally
disbelieve in the safety or efficacy of
evidence-based pharmacology or other
medical treatments and instead they turn
to alternative medicine like detoxes but
when it comes to detox is like these
we're talking about ineffective
treatments for problems that are
unspecified or even non-existent in some
cases many people are trying to bounce
back after doing something they consider
unhealthy like binge drinking gaining a
bunch of weight or eating poorly but
there is no substitute for common-sense
solutions to improve your well-being
like eating a balanced diet exercising
doing what your doctor tells you the
reason your doctor won't tell you to go
on a crash Cleanse diet where you only
eat lemon juice and kale for 14 days or
tell you to go spend a weekend at a
sweat lodge to rid yourself of toxins is
because it doesn't work and it would be
immoral for them to recommend it if you
want to learn more about actual
science-based nutrition and physiology
check out class central you can check
out the course they offer from Yale
University called the science of
well-being or the course from Johns
Hopkins University called chemicals and
health click the link in the description
to start searching for top-rated College
lectures from world-renowned
universities on almost any topic you can
think of class central offers tens of
thousands of University course ism on
business science math computer
programming politics economics almost
anything you can imagine many of those
courses are totally free check it out at
class - central com / Pakman or just
click the link under this video if you
are watching on YouTube